اسمعك مريم بس لكن هناك مشكله دائما في
الاتصالات الاتصالات مقطوعه لليوم الرابع
على التوالي وبالتالي نواجه دائما
اشكاليات في هذه الاتصالات والانترنت
المقطوعين بفعل تجريف قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لعده مناطق في قطاع غزه وايضا
بسبب الاستهداف المباشر ل طواقم شركه
الاتصالات الفلسطينيه التي تحاول صيانه
هذه الخطوط لكن تستهدفها القوات
الاسرائيليه واستشهد اثنين اول امس جراء
هذا الاستهداف من قبل قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي عندما قصفت هذه الطواقم وهي
تحاول عمل صيانه للخطوط التي قطعتها قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي المتوغلة
الى الوصول الى المستشفى ومن ثم توجه
سيارات الاسعاف ان كانت قادره على التوجه
الى هذا المكان الذي يتم استهدافه ويتم
قصفه ويتم بكل
تاكيد تدمير المنازل على رؤوس السكان
القصف الاسرائيلي مازال مستمرا على مناطق
مختلفه في خانيونس ربما القصف هو الاشد هو
الاكثر حده هو الاكثر كثافه لا سما حي
المناره حي قزان النجار منطقه جورت اللوت
البطن السمين وكلها مناطق تقع في الجنوب
الشرقي لمدينه خانيونس وه هذه المناطق
باتت تتعرض الى القصف الاعنف لا سما بعد
دخول الدبابات الاسرائيليه وتوغل من هذه
من هذا المحور وبالتالي القصف بات مكثفا
على هذه المناطق بالاضافه الى استهداف
منطقه وسط البلد في خانيونس هذه المناطق
تتعرض الان الى قصف من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه وما بين فينا واخرى نحن في
رفح وفي اقصى رفح في اقصى الجنوب لكن رغم
كل ذلك نحن نسمع اصوات الانفجارات وهذا
دليل على ان هذه انفجارات عنيفه تدك
الدبابات الاسرائيليه هذه المناطق بعنف من
خلال القذائف المدفعيه ايضا المناطق
الوسطى مخيم المغازي ومخيم البريج يتعرضان
الى قصف عنيف كذلك مدينه غزه التي تتعرض
ما بين الفينه والاخرى الى غارات مكثفه
وتستهدف في جلها منازل مدنيه فلسطينيه
طبعا نريد ان نذكر في كل مره هشام بوضع
الاهالي بعد تركهم لهذه المواقع التي
تستهدف يعني ماذا بعد استهدافهم في خان تس
يعني هناك حديث عن تكدس لعائلات وافراد
بعدد كبير في مواقع ضيقه جدا داخل رفح
حدثنا عن هذا
الجانب بالفعل مريم رفح باتت مدينه مكتظه
والمنازل فيها ربما هي المنازل الاكثر
ازدحاما في العالم لان السكان جميعهم
توجهوا الى رفح الجيش الاسرائيلي يقصف كل
مناطق قطاع غزه بما فيها المدينه بما فيها
دير البلح بما فيها خانيونس وبالتالي رفح
رغم ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يطلب من السكان
ان توجهوا اليها الا انه يقصفها بكل تاكيد
رفح ليست بعيده عن القصف الاسرائيلي لكن
هي ربما الاقل حده والاقل كثافه في عملي
القصف الاسرائيلي وبالتالي الناس تلجا
اليها بحثا عن مكان امن لكن رغم كل ذلك
هناك نقص في المساعدات هناك نقص في
الادويه هناك نقص في الاحتياجات ومقومات
الحياه والاهم من كل ذلك الماوى هناك نقص
شديد في الماوى في مدينه رفح اذا كنا
نتحدث عن 300,000 نسمه كانوا يسكنون رفح
فاليوم اكثر من مليون و300 ال نسمه يسكنون
رفح وهم بحاجه الى كل شيء هم بحاجه بدايه
من الخيمه الى الماوى وهذا غير متوفر
اعداد الناس كبيره وفي كل يوم هناك نازحون
ياتون الى رفح بحثا عن الامن والامان لكن
رغم كل ذلك هناك الشوارع ممتلئه المساكن
ممتلئه الحدائق ممتلئه المستشفيات ممتلئه
كل مكان لك ان تتخيلي في مدينه رفح هو
ممتلئ هناك اناس بكل ما تحمل الكلمه من
معنى على الشوارع على الارصفه بدون اي نوع
من انواع الاغطيه او الفراش بسبب عدم
توفرها في مدينه رفح التي باتت مكتظه عن
بكره ابيها هناك ازدحام شديد لا تستطيع
التحرك لمسافه 100 متر او اقل او اكثر
قليلا الا بمرور وقت كبير وبالتالي
الازدحام الكبير يعرض حياه هؤلاء الناس
للخطر بفعل نقص الادويه نقص المستلزمات
البنيه التحتيه لم تعد تكفي ولكن ان
تتخيلي ان المياه تصل الى كل منزل في رفح
كل 10 ايام يوم واحد وهناك مناشدات عده من
السكان في مدينه رفح للبلديه لمصلحه
بلديات مصلحه بلديات مياه الساحل
المسؤولين عن هذه المياه ولجنه الطوارئ في
رفح بتوفير المياه ان استطاعوا ذلك لان
الكميات قليله للغايه ومن المعروف ان
اسرائيل قطعت امدادات المياه عن القطاع
وبالتالي الاوضاع في رفح صعبه للغايه شكرا
لك هشام زقوت من
رفح